you know i have to ask you about iron
man 2.
so nowadays we look at
any sized role in a marvel movie and
think that it can be a game changer for
someone
but back when the mcu was first in its
infancy
infancy with a movie like iron man 2.
what were your expectations going into a
movie like that with that
sized role did you have hopes that it
would pave the way to a larger role in
the franchise did you have any
understanding of what this franchise
could possibly become
i remember i like had the me i had a
meeting with john favreau for that
and they had said to me like it's a very
very small part but it's with
robert downey and john and like it'll be
really fun
and a lot of times they bring these
characters back into bigger more
substantial roles that was sort of it
wasn't a promise but it was a
it was definitely uh something that was
hinted at to me so
that's the reason why i even took the
meeting was because i
because i thought well if there's a
chance of it then like why not
spend an evening working with
robert downey jr and john favreau like
great i love them both
they're amazing it'll be it'll be a good
experience and
you know that's exactly what it ended up
being it ended up being nothing more
than that
but it really was fun and we were
shooting till like four in the morning
and um but yeah it's a it's a
weird i guess uh cameo that
turned into really nothing but i don't
mind you know
it's a cameo that really did make an
impression though i mean
it's it's a good sequence and i feel
like this is
because we're steeped in marvel content
all the time but i've seen a lot of
lists where it's
it's something along the lines of i feel
like wasted is the wrong word but like
an
actor who was wasted in a marvel
like they should have made more of you
being part of that movie but
i still think it's a nice a nice scene
and it was a really
impact it really was fun and like robert
downey is he
was just improving the whole time so it
was just a
it was fun to be able to work with with
him for sure
um so i don't i don't regret it but it
is
funny i'm like what was i doing what was
i doing in that
you